hello there guys and welcome to another
video regarding spider-man no way home
in this video we're going to be
discussing some leaked details about a
fight scene between doctor strains and
spider-man and before we get into the
details of the scene um i do want to say
there will be spoilers ahead so if you
want to go in completely blind and you
know have no knowledge of this fight
scene or some leaked details that i'm
going to discuss then click away now
without warning out away let's get
straight into the video we know that
both of these avengers are set to go toe
to toe as a plot unfolds in this film
and we just so happen to have some
exclusive details on how it will go down
following an altercation between the two
inside of the sanctum peter swipes an
artifact from steven's collection a
glimpse of this artifact can actually be
seen in the trailer this is the cube
that peter carries during the chase
sequence the cube's nature is actually
original to the mcu and not something
that has been seen in the marvel comics
before but more on that later in the
video peter's advantage in this chase is
his use of speed agility and spider
sense to avoid any sort of dangers from
his enemies but this isn't just any
ordinary foe this is the master domestic
art steven will have all sorts of tricks
up his sleeve during this chase and even
his cloak of levitation will get into
the act we have exclusively learned that
during this chase sequence there will be
a point when steven will actually use
the cloak of levitation to try and trap
spider-man during this chase so by
technicality peter would don strange's
iconic cloak at one point during the
chase sequence much like his variant
counterpart in what if but rather than
save him it will hold peter in place and
bring him back to strange in order to
confront him directly as to what happens
after that world fans will just have to
wait and see how it will unfold when
spider-man no way home hits feeders in
december 2021. now i'm going to go back
to the part about this cube that we see
in the trailer and how it's new to the
mcu and we haven't seen it before well
actually before this official trailer
came out there was a plot leak
um about spider-man no way home and in
this plot leak they actually spoke about
this cube now if i remember the cube was
actually some type of
multiversal prison where the sinister
six were actually imprisoned inside of
this cube and you know being trapped by
doctor strange well what happens is
peter interacts with green goblin
and he actually manipulates peter and
gets him to
try help him escape because he says
something like you know if you don't
save us we'll end up you know being
transported back and killed in their
universes and and obviously peter not
wanting them to die you know agrees to
him and you know tries to help him
escape so he doesn't you know meet his
supposed fate of death so that's why
doctor strange is you know really angry
in the trailer and he's trying to get
this cooper back from peter and you know
he has this fight that you can see
because you know peter's helping the
villains escape which he doesn't know
but obviously doctor strange knows and
obviously the villains were successful
in escaping and henceforth the
multiverse is opened up when the
villains you know from the different
universes from toby maguire's and andrew
garfield's universe all come together
into the main mcu and then i guess they
have to try stop this but would that be
successful we don't know i guess we just
have to wait and see so guys what do you
think of this plot league do you like
the sound of this do you think the idea
of a multiverse or prison is cool also
just take this with a grain of salt as
well as none of this is confirmed but i
believe we'll see more of this stuff in
the second trailer which is meant to
release the end of october or early
november anyway if you guys enjoyed this
video please leave a like and also
comment down below if you want to see
more commentary videos like this thanks
for watching guys